Paul Rubens The pioneering comedian and
actor best known as Pee-wee Herman
passed away from cancer the Beloved
performer was just 70 years old and fans
and colleagues across the world are
devastated to hear that this
extraordinarily funny artist is no
longer with us Morgan Fairchild shared a
heartbreaking tweet I am devastated to
hear of the passing of my friend Paul
Rubens he kept canceling lunch and
offers to get together but I had no idea
he was suffering so much my love and
white light to him and his family Carl
Weathers also weighed in on Reuben's
talents and kindness tweeting oh man
Pee-wee Herman has ridden off to Heaven
rest in peace Paul Rubens you made yours
truly a fan Saturday Night Live original
cast member laraine Newman wrote Paul
and I first met in 1973 at Cal Arts we
remained friends for the next 50 years
not day to day just the kind of friend
that you can text out of nowhere or have
a three hour lunch with and don't get me
started on the birthday text you send
them all day I feel sick